thank you to curiositystream and nebula
for sponsoring this video check out the
link in the description below
in 2020 americans bought 296 000
electric cars and
600 000 electric bikes around the world
there's this quiet revolution taking
place in bike lanes people are drawn to
electric bikes for their speed their
assistance in getting up hills and dare
i say it because they're cool but is
this a fad or do e-bikes live up to the
hype a couple of weeks ago i got myself
an electric bike this is a ridgeback
arcus 1 which isn't the cheapest bike
you can get but it's definitely on the
affordable end of the spectrum and this
isn't sponsored but i got this from
central bikes in london for a really
good deal this was
1170 pounds i think it'd be fair to say
that one of the major worries people
have about e-bikes is their range and
this thing has a status range of 50
kilometers to test that i have a meeting
in bristol this morning which is almost
exactly 25 kilometers away from where we
now live so i'm going to see if i can
get there and back over some pretty
significant hills on a single charge
there's a lot of confusion about what
exactly an e-bike is and what it does so
in the uk you have four types of
electric bikes electrically assisted
pedal cycles or eapcs speed pedal x
electric mopeds and electric motor bikes
those last three categories all require
some form of registration and license
normally a compulsory basic training the
same as if you were to ride any kind of
motorbike my bike is an eapc the most
common kind of electric bike you don't
have to pay road tax you don't need to
have a license of any kind though you do
need to be over 14 to ride one and you
don't need to register it the key thing
about ea pcs is that the electric motor
which has to be less than 250 watts will
only assist you in cycling whilst you
are using the pedals it's not a throttle
it just supplements your mechanical
effort and it only does so up to 25
kilometers per hour you can go faster
than that such as if you're going down a
hill but the electric motor won't help
you go any faster normally these bikes
have toggleable electric support so you
can choose if you're getting a lot of
support or nothing at all you can ride
it as a normal bike if you want so on my
bike specifically you have your 8-speed
gearbox over here with your flappy
paddles and then you also have your
level of support which is this number up
here in the corner of the screen the
screen itself you can change to display
different things like the distance
covered or your speed or what have you
and then you can change your level of
support with these two buttons one of
the reasons why i got this bike in
particular was because the battery is
removable so if you have a key it goes
in the ignition if you like and you can
just twist the battery off now that
gives you a bit of extra security so if
you want to park the bike up you can
take the battery with you because who's
going to nick an electric bike without
the battery but also it means that you
can remove the battery for charging
overnight so the bike can just stay in
the shed i don't have to bring it into
the house in order to charge it in my
experience the battery will charge in a
couple of hours i think they say about
three hours for 50 charge i think that's
a bit pessimistic it's been a bit faster
than that for me but generally you just
leave it overnight perhaps the most
pressing question here is what's it
actually like to ride one of these
things and the answer to that is
basically it's like a normal bike for
the first half turn full turn of the
pedals it's at that point that the motor
kicks in so if i pull away now
i'll get about one turn in
and then
the motor kicks in and it's like you're
just being pulled along by a fishing
line or something it's like an extra
force it's kind of weird but really fun
now most of the ways of bristol from
here is downhill
so i'm going to keep it on this
low level of support
until i really need it there are a
couple of bits where it might be nice to
have a bit of a boost like going over a
bridge but for the most part i'm just
getting a little light push right now
i'm just i'm just getting a little bit
of support
okay let's not mount the camera like
that again
there are plenty of misconceptions i
think around electric bikes some people
seem to think they're cheating or that
they're for only elderly people or for
unfit people but i'd like to point out
that tour de france winners use them as
their daily drivers i think ultimately
it comes down to why you want to get a
bike in the first place the reason i got
an e-bike is because i don't view
cycling as a leisure past time it's not
something i do for fun it's something i
do to get from a to b and i got an
e-bike rather than a regular bike
because where i live is as you can
probably tell from all these shots very
beautiful but it's also very very hilly
for example this is ralph allen drive
one of the most infamous hill ascent out
of bath it's a kilometer long give or
take and it has a bit over 100 meters of
height game so it's a pretty monstrous
hill i wouldn't want to cycle up this
hill normally i wouldn't want to walk up
it normally so this evening i thought i
would take the bike out
and try and take it up the hill see how
it does so naturally i've put it in the
higher support mode because i fear death
and uh hopefully we'll get to the top in
one piece now something i have noticed
with this bike is that
it's not that you don't notice the hills
it's not quite magic
and you don't go at the same speed that
you would on the flat
like i'm already slowing down to like
about 17 kilometers per hour now
the thing is
it just
it takes the sting out the hill it's
almost like you take this
and you just
level it out it becomes a nice gentle
gradient rather than a
sucking great big hill
but my legs feel
fine i feel like i could kind of do this
for a very long time
plus as well
ashley to see how much difference the
assist is making i'm on top assist right
now
i'll just take off all the levels and go
down to absolutely nothing
oh god oh
yeah okay
this bike tricks you into thinking
you're actually fitter than you are
you're like i'm going up this hill so
easily
sure it's not that bad then yeah
you take the levels off and it's uh it's
bad
okay come on come on murray you can do
this
there we go
okay my legs feel like
they have done a little bit of a workout
but nowhere near as much
as if i'd done that unassisted my word
sorry that sounded way more aggressive
than i wanted to
oh oh
oh god this road surface could do with a
bit of work it's like driving over a
teenager's face
it's not london certainly not amsterdam
the bath's got some pretty nice
cycling infrastructure
and some very nice places to cycle okay
so i'm now on the long flat straight
of this route i'm now on the cycle path
between bath and bristol
and that means i'm gonna
up the support slightly
uh just because we don't have that long
gradient i'll go from support level two
to support level three
you do have to remember of course that
once you do hit 25 kph
motor will stop supporting you so at
this point i'm just under my own steam
but it's maintaining at this point
as i've already mentioned one of the
main advantages of an e-bike is that it
helps you get up hills that bit easier
but there are other advantages firstly
even though you're assisted in doing so
it does get you out and about and doing
more exercise i'm definitely doing more
exercise now from cycling the bike yes i
have an electric motor that does some of
the work but i'm still doing more
exercise than i would have done
otherwise secondly compared to other
forms of transport they are incredibly
cheap to run you don't need to pay tax
or insurance don't maybe you should get
insurance anyway and in terms of filling
up if you like the cost works out
something like a penny per mile and
thirdly frankly they're really fun to
ride i found that when i first picked up
the bike in london i was pulling away
from traffic lights so much more easily
and i was just bombing around central
london the fact that you're electrically
assisted up to 25 kph means that the
less enjoyable bits of cycling like
pulling away from traffic lights or
going up hills are just that bit more
enjoyable and the whole experience is a
lot more fun
so what are the principal disadvantages
well obviously cost
if you are looking to buy a regular bike
then you can spend 100 pounds and get
something half decent that works
for an e-bike realistically it's about a
thousand pounds for the same kind of
equipment you can also argue that the
extraction and use of rare earth
materials in the battery can have a
negative environmental effect in places
where they're mined which is a very
legitimate argument and of course it's
actually kind of worse if you use an
electric bike and you get your
electricity from fossil fuels rather
than renewable sources
now at this point google maps decided to
take me a little bit um off-piste i
wasn't expecting this
why is this place that's a cyclable
surface isn't it
a mic kind of different route back
i don't think google quite got this
wasn't really a psychopath
okay maybe this is why it isn't a cycle
route hey it's clogging up my chain now
there's a problem i hadn't anticipated
no no this was all part of the test i
thought i thought i would test it on
offroad as well
here's the
destination
this is queen square
ah
what time is it
oh i'm eight minutes early so this thing
took me 15 miles
25-ish kilometers and
then if you can see on here we've got
about 60 battery left and i finished in
sort of low support mode again the route
back to bath is a little more uphill so
i'm feeling pretty confident about how
much battery i've got left i am
concerned that at the very end of the
route there is a sucking great big hill
so we'll have to see if that uh that's
enough juice
it's interesting to compare the carbon
intensity of different forms of travel
so how much carbon is emitted into the
atmosphere per kilometer that you travel
in a particular way perhaps
unsurprisingly flying is the most carbon
intense way to travel and international
rail perhaps surprisingly is the least
carbon intense way to travel unless of
course you account for electric bikes
using my bike as an example by my rough
calculations electric bikes emit around
one and a half grams of co2 for every
kilometer traveled except that is
assuming your average uk carbon
intensity of generating electricity
pixelgirl and i actually use a company
called bulb supplier electricity who
only use renewable energy which means
that actually my bike has a carbon
intensity of zero grams of co2 emitted
for every kilometer that i travel on it
in fact the only co2 that's emitted
associated with traveling on an electric
bike is associated with the calories
that you consume in order to push the
bike yourself which is kind of wild so i
just had a meeting here i can't actually
say what it was about but it was about a
secret future project which i really
hope you can see in a couple of months
but um that's all i can say for now now
however i've got to get back home i've
actually got to jump on a video call so
back on the bike
it's pretty hot now it's it's a lot
hotter than what i get here this morning
now you might well say okay simon but
you've not actually been using the bike
to its full capacity on this entire trip
like you've turned the support down so
it's not really a fair test of the range
and to that i'd say well one of the key
advantages of the bike is the
flexibility that it gives you being able
to dial the amount of support that you
get into the bike means that you can use
the battery in an intelligent way you
can have a small amount of support when
you don't need it and a large amount of
support when you do need it and on this
trip and in this heat i was going to be
as frugal as possible
because well i am nearly back home
there's just one big hill that i need to
get up the bike is currently on
and if you can see that two bars so
hopefully
for 25 30 maybe battery i've been very
frugal and i don't know if you can tell
i'm sweating quite a bit because
well partly i've been frugal and partly
it's i think the hottest day of the year
so
it's been tough i really hope i've got
enough for this one because considering
how hot it is
i need all the help i can get to get up
this hill
still on two bars
pretty sure we're gonna make this okay
i'm not gonna say that this is easy
especially in this heat but it's so much
easier than if i was doing this
i just wouldn't even try
okay we just went down to one bar of
battery
i've adopted the cycling position that
my friend calls the prawn
not far from the top now
we can't be much juice left on the tank
at this point
maybe 10
okay the battery has just started
flashing
which means it's on 10
but
i've just made it since up the hill
ah and there
we
go
i'll be honest i did not expect this to
make 50 kilometers on a single charge i
thought that i'd have a really hellish
ascent up that final hill but
it's such an impressive piece of kit it
just works honestly getting an e-bike
was one of my best decisions
ever i think this is one of my favorite
purchases one of my best purchases like
ever it's just revolutionized how i get
myself around how
like what i'm able to do in the local
area by myself
i think perhaps the way to look at
electric bikes is not as a bike
replacement
they're a car replacement sure they
don't do long distances for short
distance traveling if you want to carry
yourself and a bit of luggage in a bag
it feels the same niche but with so many
more advantages it's more flexible it's
cheaper it's better for your health and
it's better for the environment they're
perfect for commuting and not turning up
to the office sweaty they tear up the
urban environment and they make cycling
and being outdoors really fun mine has
yet to let me down really in any way
in short in my experience electric bikes
live up to the hype
i've become a participant in the
transportation revolution relying on an
electric vehicle and decarbonized
electricity sources to get around and
that's not a revolution unique to bike
lanes with electric cars electric planes
and electric boats all in the near
future how we'll transport ourselves in
the future is going to be of critical
importance with respect to the climate
emergency something that's the topic of
an episode of dream the future called
transportation of the future this is a
documentary series available on
curiositystream the sponsor of today's
video and the number one source of high
quality documentaries on the web
episodes in the series include how we'll
cook in the future how we'll deal with
waste in the future and even how we'll
work in the future but if you'd prefer
something a little different curiosity
stream has literally thousands of titles
across a wide range of subjects from the
super serious to the light-hearted if
you sign up for curiosity stream at
curiositystream.com simon clark linked
in the description not only will you get
26 off your subscription you'll also get
free access to nebula the streaming
award nominated streaming service that i
co-own along with a huge number of other
youtube educators nebula has original
exclusive content extended cuts of our
videos on youtube and no ads whatsoever
in the videos or on the website or in
the app by signing up for curiosity
stream and nebula you get the best of
both worlds small indie creators and big
budget documentaries and you directly
support the development of educational
online video nebula is like our
playground our testing ground for new
ideas so that's curiositystream.com
simon clark for 26 off and to directly
support this channel thank you to
curiositystream for sponsoring this
video
thank you so much for watching the video
this one was a lot more hands-on
practical to make which i really liked
so i hope you liked watching it
definitely check out the link on screen
right now for curiosity stream nebula
and if you'd like to watch something
else here's some recommended viewing as
well thanks again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one